Speaker 1: All right.
We now have our latest Tears in my Eyes story
from Infowars conspiracy theorist Alex Jones.
And I want to play a couple of different things
for you.
One, this is very short, but it's just to
set the stage of where Alex Jones currently
is in his sort of public discourse and dialog.
Alex Jones said yesterday that Carrie Lake
is really the governor of Arizona.
Now, this is not something that there is debate.
You know, when I was on with Lex Freedman
a couple of weeks ago, he said this thing
about how, you know, isn't everything sort
of an opinion at this point?
And I said, no, it's really not it is not
up for debate whether Carrie Lake is the governor
of Arizona.
Katie Hobbs received more votes in November
of 2022.
In that race, Katie Hobbs was inaugurated
as the governor of Arizona.
And Katie Hobbs is the governor of Arizona.
It's not a matter of opinion, but listen to
Alex Jones.
You can always trust him, to tell you the
truth.
Right?
Speaker 2: We have to continue to expose what's
happening.
We have to get integrity in elections.
There's total fraud.
Arizona is the perfect example.
Carrie Lake's an incredible champion of freedom
there.
She's obviously really the governor.
The person that ran the election, I believe,
stole the election from me.
Speaker 1: She's obviously really the governor.
There is no way in which Carrie Lake is really
the governor.
And what I think is really important about
these sorts of clips is when people write
to me and they say, you know, Alex Jones was
right about this.
Alex Jones was right about that.
He's the only one you can really trust these
exact sorts of declarations.
I say them so confidently with the total.
Sometimes it's it's arrogance and sometimes
it's condescension.
Kerry Lake is obviously really the governor.
How do you not know that, you moron?
There is no way in which Kerry like is the
governor.
Now, let's move on to the Tears in my Eyes
story.
Alex Jones now says when he goes to liberal
areas in Austin, Texas, which he admits it's
where the good restaurants are.
Listen.
That's true.
The good restaurants in Austin are absolutely
in the liberal areas.
He says everybody comes up to him now and
says, we were wrong.
You were right about everything.
This is sort of like they came up to me with
tears in their eyes and said, Sir, you've
been treated so unfairly.
Here's Alex Jones version of that story.
Speaker 2: With the pain of being prominent,
not having privacy.
You actually get a real gauge.
I go to the most liberal areas of Austin now
that I avoided for years.
I saw the best restaurants without even security
now.
Wow.
And literally, I go in a restaurant and almost
everyone comes over and says, We're sorry.
We were wrong.
We know the government is evil.
We know the country's been hijacked.
I just took my wife, went to dinner with some
friends last Thursday.
And almost everybody in the restaurant came
over an Italian restaurant, black, white,
Hispanic, all young.
Then I walked to the parking garage, ran to
three groups of people and black, white, Hispanic.
Every group said, We love you.
We're sorry.
Speaker 1: They all said.
Speaker 2: It.
You should think we're bad.
So that shows me years in the most leftist
areas.
They're even converting.
And there is a real global awakening.
There is a great awakening happening as the
counter to the Great Race.
Speaker 1: What's really funny is you can't
find evidence of this anywhere.
Like think for a second what it would mean
if all of a sudden the entirety of liberal
progressive woke Austin, Texas, was so overcome
with the undeniable truth of the things Alex
Jones has been saying, that they now go up
to him and say, You've converted me.
We were wrong.
In fact, I think think about what Alex Jones
wants you to believe.
Before he needed security in liberal areas
because people would come up to him and I
guess threaten him or maybe you cost him or,
you know, whatever.
Now the progressive left has become so overcome
and enamored with Alex Jones for telling the
truth about the evil government that he no
longer needs security.
The liberals who used to pose a physical threat
to him requiring him to have security.
Now they come up and say, You were right about
everything.
Does anyone believe these stories?
I certainly don't.
If you do, then please leave a comment.
Send an email.
I want to hear from you.